I love this movie I'm sure it's a very
tough day doing press when everyone
comes in loving something so was this
that when you were offered this or
discussed this with Ryan was this the
fastest you said yes to something you
know what yes
indeed uh in my mind I had always said
if Ryan reaches out to me I don't care
if it's a two-second commercial it's a
yes and you know I've read the script I
was already a fan of his taste and
everything and I was like
after reading it dream role Dreamcast
we got to go to Greece I mean it was so
terrible going to Greece and The Baklava
and all those things uh no it was it was
like a once in a lifetime thing you just
say yes just these sort of special
um murder mysteries that that he's
making and innovating in and my
character is like
a dream because I got an opportunity to
really really show range and go to
different places
um as an actor that I hadn't necessarily
gone to yeah
a year and a half into lockdown when the
phone rang and said caller unknown I
picked it up and went yes
somebody take me
[Music]
this it was an easy yes it was it was um
it was particularly
it's not unlike miles's friends getting
the invite from him the way that Kate
Hudson you know throws her hand in the
air that was pretty much all of us on
this film no spoilers no spoilers right
um the thing about this though is both
of you guys have such well-written
characters that are three-dimensional
and you know funny and serious
um did you realize how funny it was when
you were reading the script or did you
really get it when you saw the first
audience screening uh when we were
reading I mean when I read it it was
laughing out loud and funny yeah and
then when I watched it for the first
time I was by myself in a small theater
you know Ryan had showed it to me at the
production office and I was like
laughing yeah it was it was a laugh out
loud funny I was just very very funny I
I am thoroughly entertained and I cannot
wait to watch this with an audience
it had it and I mean he I'd say
almost everyone Ryan's amazing because
he he's so relaxed and he's so
authentically inviting of actors to say
you know riff dude you know he he brings
people who he wants them to goof around
he wants them to toss in a you know off
the cuff idea
but all that relaxation is a function of
how meticulous he is ironically as a
Craftsman it's so well built the
baseline's so strong that I think he's
you know he's he's like you know yeah
you wanna if we can add on to it great
but but everybody's in a state of
relaxation with him
um that's very rare because his
fundamentals are so great when you were
looking at the schedule and you're
seeing all the stuff you need to do what
was the day that you had circled like I
cannot wait to get to set that day
I mean for me
it was
every day like I I hate to be cliche in
that way but it's just true the truth I
actually loved working with each and
every last cast member there was a bond
that happened because this was in the
middle of a pandemic so there was a sort
of bubble that we had to stay in and and
be in so that we didn't get sick we
couldn't go out and be at the clubs in
Greece we had to like stay together and
we we spent a lot of good time together
that allowed for so much trust as actors
when it was time to go there and take
risks and just trusted the person that
you were with that they had your best
interests and they were super giving
when it was you know your close-up
moments um so I was excited about the
whole experience to learn to watch uh to
just like yeah to like stay in this
summer camp if you will like it was like
a summer camp you did not want your
parents to come and get you from
without ruining it for anybody but there
is a moment where Benoit Blanc
um
uncorks his detective prowess in a very
unexpected way
you know disrupting some of my
characters plans and uh for a game and
he I thought it was so it was really
funny on paper and I was dying to see
Daniel do that bit
um yeah there was also funny exchange
the thing about like someone wins and he
says what do you win you know and the
thing about like an iPad
I was that that dinner too the dinner
table scene in the beginning of the
murder mystery game among the characters
had a lot going on that I was really
excited with there are lots of twists in
this film so once I was shocked like
when reading it I was like oh I did not
see that coming so I think for me it was
just seeing how we were going to play
that and yeah that's that that was
something that I was excited to sink my
teeth into need to go thank you so much
for your time thank you and seriously
congrats on the movie thank you